today i'm going to be talking about the
interact-normal plan
monoclonal antibody blood performance
characterization
within a test protein workflow a massive
advisor firm software
so the instruments that we utilize in
the collected data i'm going to show you
later on in the presentation
is utilizing our 6545 xp
which has a lot of unique features for
large biomolecule analysis
so down here we have the shell of the
instrument and we have our flight tube
the flight tube has an ultra low vacuum
of 10 to the minus eight torr
this helps with excellent special
natural clarity of your proteins
this system also has a one-click
optimization perfect for large molecule
analysis
utilizing the foreign autotune in a mass
hunter
acquisition this system is capable of
analyzing very large molecules
up to thirty thousand and over z
upon installation of this utop a protein
performance verification will be
conducted
this system also contains eventually
capillary
removal now by the system that you can't
see the handle here
that will control a d valve that
isolates the vacuum behind the capillary
this enables you to remove the capillary
either clean it or replace it
without having to vent the instrument
and wait for the system to pump back
down
to your final vacuum this way to be back
up and running to collect your data
within minutes
for the impact working characterization
we use the agilent 1290 infinity 2lc
stack
as shown here there are a variety of
in-style llc columns
shown here that can be used for in-text
working characterization
the video that was shown in this
presentation was using the porps
1000 angstrom columns
the plrpf column consists of polystyrene
or ventral benzene beads
they come in a variety of four sizes
from 100 to 4000 angstroms
and products with sizes ranging from
three to ten and even higher
some of the features of this column
consists of a yph range from one to
fourteen
the capability of handling extreme
buffer concentrations
less than eight molar high temperature
stability
and this column can be used for both
gradient or isotropic illusions
some of the applications that utilize
this column are
iph separations oligonucleotides
the analysis of very large molecules
there's also a good
alternative selectivity to c18
so the particles in the clrps column
are currently hydrofolded so there are
no bonded phases
there's a typically an alkyl login
that's required for
reverse base separation this is a highly
reproducible material
as can be seen these octagon across to
the images
these particles are also free from
thylanias and heavy metal ions
for the intact nest neb analysis
workflow we have our liquid
chromatography parameters shown here on
the left in this table
and the religious chromatography system
we realized through the study was
the agilent 1290 infinity to uh
elc system they use the plrps column 2.1
by 15 millimeter
1000 action 5 micron
for solving a and b you have water with
21 percent formic acid
and ac nitrile is 0.1 formic acid
respectively
our gradient natural factors empty up to
70 percent b
and that's up to 5 percent b the column
was
maintained at 60 degrees c the flow rate
of 0.5 mils per minute was
utilized we look at a series of
concentrations injected on columns
but today i'm going to show you today
with some 100 nanogram injections on
columns
the ms acquisition parameters are shown
here on the right
then we use our agilent 55 45 xt
advanced bios control system
the source we utilize was the dual ags
source
with a gas temperature of 350 degrees c
and the sheath gap temperature of 400
degrees c
our v cap was maintained at 5500 volts
with a nozzle voltage of 2000 volts
we collected data over a mass range of
300 to 7000
m over z utilizing a reference mass of
922
after the human node there's positive
high 10000m overzea mass range
for the data analysis we used by
performance software
which has three main predominant
workflows and then tag protein workflow
part-time mapping workflow and aggregate
analysis workflow
for the anti-protein characterization
workflow
now simplifies the firm is utilized for
the data analysis
where the software integrates peak the
mixture of spectrum
it would then become a limited charge
envelope
and if the sequence was provided
automatically match sequence
then define a crystal form and can
generate a report
if necessary
some of the new features of bias of firm
10 include the following
for the intact protein workload we can
now guide your
of the relative quantitation of your
post-translational modifications
as shown here and i'll discuss even more
detail
protein digest workflow consists of
relative connotation of your full
translational modifications in
a table in history or format multiple
style comparisons
when you release parking workflow it
allows you to now do
relative connotation of your glycogen in
the table histogram format
and architecture amount of levels files
this has a new layout button to improve
the usability of switching between his
rework force
this new layout buttons allow you to
change easily between the workflows
so you can change easily from the
interact working workflow to the digest
workflow or the glide to the workflows
just by clicking on these buttons
you can customize a layout for any of
the three workflows
save the layout and you can also assign
it to one of these stores
also in the interact working workflow i
can also use this unspecified device
cell phi linkages
what is this this feature allows the
software to calculate the correct
intact mass of your biomolecule without
requiring you to manually
input all the different linkages so if
you look here
the intense mismatch has approximately
16 total diastole by linkages
and instead of having to type in these
15 linkages
manually this tells you how you input
how many of the 16
possible decimals and linkages are
linked
you type in the number and it'll
automatically calculate
the correct impact mask for you without
having to manually type in
all 16 by software languages
when you go into buy prefer then the
workflow i think one
sequences running in text or team
workforce with address outside links
here
you would just click on specified
the entire protein layout and biographer
is shown here
at the top we have our sample table this
just tells you what samples are
currently opened in biographer
your simple chromatogram they are
extracted by a monogenatogram
the mass spectrum both of the centroid
and profile view
the convoluted spectrum the world's
relative quantitation histogram the
biomolecule table
you can value your biomiles as you
started in your data
there's this column here that's used for
percent one
and you can select the biomolecule to
use your relative
annotation by selecting the checkbox
or if you do not want to enter for also
quantitation you can deselect a checkbox
and the histogram will update
accordingly to your selection
and by the firm this is just the
view of the connotations histogram so if
you want to use a feature for real quick
quantitation you select it
you don't want to use it you deselect it
and the system will update accordingly
escape these entities by by molecular id
or by sample
and i'll show an example of this later
on in our presentation
also combine the term ameroplot of
e-commerce spectra
this allows for fast comparison of two
samples
so here we sample one sample two
this dotted line here with the
differential clause
this allows you to see if your
biosimilars are the same
or they're different from each other
now on to the data here we have our
antagonist now
you can see a 200 nanogram ejection on
the bone
with the entire shape distribution here
ranging from about 2000
to 5000 m over z if we zoom in on a few
of these charge shapes here
they could see our glycogen pattern on
each of these charge states over the
negativities of
means so then these are the charge rate
distributions
if now we perform maximum attribute
deconvolution of this data
we see our various compositions of gof
t1f and g2 of glycoforms the readiness
and triplicate
we've got our mass accuracy for these
cycle forms shown here
they can see our average for the triple
conjunction
is under 60 cm but our relatively small
standard deviation
so not only do they work with math
accuracy the delivery for disability on
the platform
for relative quantitation distribution
of implementation
we have our average organizational forms
as well as a standard deviation shown
here
we can do the relative quantitation and
you know
there is a histogram that is biomolecule
id
so when graphing inside by module id
each of these columns represents
women those one of the replicas
so the ripple get one and black two and
right
and three in green you should use
grouping surfaces with a different
combination of the plastic forms that
are found on the nest map
and we can see throughout the
quantitation prevention triple data
injection
that's highly reproducible from one to
one to one
we can also prove the relative
quantitation has to do
by sample so now each
replicate is a different grouping so
complicate one
replicant two roughly fifth three
and each color represents a different
quadriform composition
and in this map
we also looked at perspective and this
resulting
strategic distribution of more
likelihood injection rating from about
2000
to 4400m overseas
we zoom in on this chart shape
distribution here we can see our global
formula
perceptive for these charge shapes
we'll need four maximum entropy
deconvolution we see our various
combinations of gof
g1s and g2f glycoforms
we also can get relative quantitation
information regarding these glycoforms
of perceptive
as shown here on the histogram plot
we also wanted to look at the lighting
heavy chains of this map
so we reduced the mismatch into the way
inhabited chain components
use the same agilent 1290 and 82
uhdlc system and use the same prps call
a 2.1 by 50 millimeter column left
outfit angstrom five micron column
and the typical reverse phase separation
solvent we'll use water as pregnant for
that formic acid
and a cni child with one percent formic
acid
so why not from zero percentage up to
seventy percent b
come back down to zero percentage
they maintain the column of sixty
degrees c with a flow rate of 0.35 mils
per minute
with the 200 nanoderm injection on
column
and the ms acquisition parameters here
for the agile
6545 xp against biology itself
as shown here on the table on the right
and here we use our dual agf source okay
the gas temperature is sheathed down by
350 degrees c
400 degrees c a v cap converts the
voltage of 5500 volts
and 2 000 volts our mass range was
500 to 3200 ml z
a reference mass high of 922 is utilized
and the acquisition mode was positive
save your 3200 m over z
mass range
into the analysis of the reduced
mismatch
thanks to this light and heavy shade of
fluids we use the last
anti-protein layer from that centre-back
the first time
so the other tic here for the right
chain
that's in this red box this is the first
beginning tic
for the next section they see charge a
distribution
ranging from about a thousand to 3200 ml
z
we zoom in on this charge d here with
the first time charge state of the right
chain
in here we have a mass resolution of
above 48 000.
when you before maximum attribute
deconvolution we see that it still
contains two
interchangeable bonds now what's
nice about this q-tip is that we're able
to obtain some extra copper stability
and the deconvolution profiles the
smallest resolution we're able to obtain
with this platform
we also looked at the heavy chain within
the staff the second piece in the tisd
shown here here's the charging
distribution that users
ranging from above 900 to about 3 000 ml
over z
and if we zoom in on some of these
charge shapes here we can use the glycol
forms retained on the mismatch to these
different charge states
under four methylene contribute
deconvolution we see that the heavy
chain
contains three interchange disulfide
bonds then we're able to identify
the three glycol forms on the heavy
chain the gof
k1f and g2f
we can get relative quantitation of
these three glycol forms on the heavy
chain of the mismata as shown here
for the glf t1f and g2f
and with that i like to thank you for
listening to this presentation